l'industrielle avait lancé on l'a
rappelé en décembre 90 un forum des
citoyens à Montfermeil en scène saintden
38 projets devaient voir le jour pour
comme il l'avait dit casser la logique
du ghetto initiative alors très
controversée qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
reportage Anne mourg et Bernard
pissoso la plupart étaient chômeur sans
formation il se croyait sans avenir
aujourd'hui caméra au point il filme la
vie de leur cité apprennent l'art du
tournage de
l'interview il y a un an vous auriez
imaginé jourd'hui vous feriez ce stage
il y a 6 mois j'imaginais même pas ça
alors il y a un an c'était j'aimerais
être caméraman travailler pour une
chaîne de télé ou à mon compte mais sera
plus le montage vous aimeriez en faire
votre métier bien sûr si si je le fais
là c'est pas pour all une peu après quoi
c'est pour continuer là-dedans ils sont
une petite poignée sélectionné parmi les
jeunes de la cité ce stage de 4 mois est
devenu possible grâce à Bernard tapi
c'est lui qui a donné un coup de pouce
au projet c'est lui qui a trouvé les
locaux permis le finance
les plus jeunes s'imaginent plutôt
sportif au top niveau grâce au soutien
de Bernard tap certains ont été à New
York pour le marathon d'autres ont gravi
l'Himalaya d'autres encore ont rencontré
Jean-Pierre Papin on a des voyages des
voyages
pour Marse Marseille non belgiqueous on
a eu des survêtements des shorts des GR
par lui c'est bien qu'il a fait dire
bien lors de sa venue à Montfermeil il y
a an tapis a beaucoup promis des
entreprises pour la cité les locaux sont
prêts ils sont au tr/art vides un
environnement plus agréable le quartier
n guerre changé les immeubles les plus
véustes n'ont pas encore été démolis
l'Alte garderie est toujours derrière la
palissade la délinquence a augmenté il y
a toujours un habitant sur ch des jeunes
qui sont
apathiques ce sont véritablement des
paumés au sens du terme et qui n'ont
aucune volonté vous voulez les mettre au
marché du travail mais pensez donc il
leur faudra 2 3 ans avant de réaliser ne
pouvez pas les mettre ce sont des gens
qui sont incapables actuellement même si
vous le donnez un emploi qui pourrait
correspondre à leur possibilité je ne
dis pas leur capacités ils n'en ont pas
à leur possibilité ou bien à ce qu'il
souhait faire mais au bout de jours ils
s'en
vont pour le maire comme pour Bernard
tapi le moyen pour ses jeune de s'en
sortir c'est d'abord de se défoncer sur
un terrain de sport découvrir l'envie de
gagner récemment le patron de l'OM a
invité à montfermeille Noah Gires pour
montrer aux jeunes que s'ils le veulent
eux aussi peuvent devenir des citoyens
hors du commun tapis a donné aux jeunes
l'envie de rêver